this morning we're going to be
continuing this idea of thinking about
the relationship between when you get a
bunch of equations right like for
example this first one and you might as
well go ahead and write this as a pair
of equations right we're thinking about
the sort of translation between these
equations and their visual counterparts
so when you see these two that's a -
isn't it when you see these two
equations we can and we will handle them
entirely as algebraic objects but the
same time the question that I'm posing
to you of all of these pairs of
equations is a visual question right
it's a geometric question find the
points of intersection these are lines
one of them is going to give us a
parabola or one of them is going to give
us a straight line and they are going to
intersect at some spots and we want to
find out where they are okay so what
we're going to do is think about how to
do this algebraically and then if you
haven't already pull up in your devices
bless you and have desmos at the ready
don't use it just yet we'll get to the
right point we want to use it to confirm
what we find not to just take a shortcut
and not actually do the thinking on this
okay so when we're finding the points of
intersection between two different
equations like this between two
different graphs represented by these
two equations as the heading suggests
what we're going to do is call on all
our knowledge of simultaneous equations
and think about solving these two
simultaneously now the reason why that
makes sense is because to find where
these two graphs exists at the same time
right what we're looking for is an x and
a y right let's solve this equation but
they also simultaneously solve this
equation right sorry in question yeah
okay so it just as an example to
illustrate why we're thinking about this
right you don't need to write this part
down but it's really easy to think of
X's and Y's that solve one of the
equations just one of them for example
if X were equal to zero here if X were
equal to zero what would the Y be well
just be 1 right because y equals zero
squared plus one so this
is a solution to this guy right but if I
try and take it over here if I want to
put x equals zero y equals one in here
wanna get here Iowa gets three lots of
zero minus one plus one what does that
equal
this is it equal zero
oh it is no no wait hold on oh yeah okay
cool right so we've got here this
satisfies both equations right so what
have we found this simultaneously
that's the point right solves both
equations it's gonna be one of the
solutions now my question to you is is
that the only one how would you know so
we can do some substitution he can't
wait right I'm gonna do it in a second
before we go
my point is before we do that like I
don't know that this is the only
solution there might be more this might
be the only one but this is a really
slow way to do it right I have to kind
of check manually and it's not very
efficient right
Reston's suggestion okay so this is what
strain was saying let's do this right
you know how to solve simultaneous
equations in lots of different ways
substitution was the first suggestion
that story made he said look this on Y
here and I can put it in over here okay
so let's go ahead and do that I'm going
to give these equations some names and
now I can work with them together so I
only go to substitute one into two
everywhere that I saw why I'm gonna
write down X square plus one just watch
out by the way bless you because there's
a minus sign here and it applies to
everything that's in the Y and this is
everything right a plus one equals zero
okay so this is a new equation that I
can go ahead and solve and hopefully it
should give me all of the solutions
potentially including the one that we
just found over here so if I go ahead
and expand this out a little bit I'm
gonna get this watch out for my signs
here
can I do any collection of like terms I
can what can I collect yep so that's
just gonna become zero so I'm going to
get 3x minus x squared equals zero like
so okay what we're trying to do with
this
I mean I did the first thing you asked
me to do which is substitute I did some
simplification just now what do you
think yep
so I could add x squared to both sides I
would then get an equation said 3x
equals x squared okay now I'm just gonna
write this over here on the side okay
this is a valid way to go about and
solving this but I'm gonna just show you
in a second why I think that that's
actually perhaps not the most helpful
thing to do I actually like having all
the X's on one side okay can someone
suggest what's a different path an
alternative path I could also take you
go ahead okay so I could factorize here
okay now what would I factorize out what
is the common factor its X isn't it so
if I take an X out I get equals zero
okay now I can actually get both of the
solutions that I want including the one
I've verified up here I can get both of
the solutions that I want out of either
of these lions okay but I want to show
you why this one I actually prefer to
this one okay when you've got this
factorize there are two factors remember
when we're looking at cubics yesterday
how many factors did we often get with a
cubic we would get three because it's X
cubed right so we didn't always but we
often got three and from each of those
factors we've got a solution I have two
factors here so I should expect two
solutions yeah one of them being the one
you already found zero but now this is
better than just trying randomly I've
got another solution right which is okay
these are the two solutions these are
the only ones now the reason why I think
this is a little more helpful
factorizing going by taking an X out is
if you have a look at this at least when
I met these back in year eight and you
did probably made the same mistake I
look at this and I'm like oh look I can
divide both sides by X which gives you
sure enough and answer right one of the
ones we already knew the only problem is
it gives you just one of the answers
right this answer is still hiding in
there 3 times 0 does equal 0 times 0
right but this way of writing it just
makes it a bit harder to see so
generally speak
factorizing is the bed way to go okay
now I've gotten to the end
I sort of like said cool I've done all
this work and I've got an x equals am I
done I am not done why not
usually we want to find X right now
found it ah
good so you're taking your cue from the
question which actually doesn't just ask
you for some X values it asks you for
points right so with each X there's
gonna be a wine okay so I've got enough
space down here I'm gonna fit it in when
x equals zero that gives me this value
we already found up here like was one
but had this other value that I also
want to substitute and find its
corresponding Y value so when X is equal
to 3 y is gonna be 3 squared plus 1
which is 10 okay now here is all the
information that I need to answer the
question but I think it's nice being
that they asked for points that we
actually provide the answer as a pair of
points do you agree with that okay
so I'm gonna get 0 comma 1 and 3 comma
10 these are the points of intersection
now I asked you before to just pull up
desmos for me okay I want to confirm and
also understand the meaning of what we
just did okay so if you take state if
you take des moss and you pop the two
original equations in that we started
with what do we got here
x squared plus one there's the first one
and then we've also is three X minus y
plus one by the way what form is that
line in three X minus y plus one we've
got a name for this fall
this is general form is it a general
form ax plus B y plus C except we've got
a 3 and negative 1 and 1 so this is what
I've got I've put both of those
equations on to here like literally like
actually I need a Y there just to make
it complete but des mots knows what I
was trying to do there we go
ok now can you see what we found and its
relevance to this equation right or to
this picture I should say right where 0
1 where is it it's it's this first point
of intersection do you agree I found
that spot by solving the equation
where's 3 comma 10 do you see where it
is it's the other spot over there right
so these are the two points that we've
found ok now just as one last little
sort of end note before we then go on to
the next one which I'm going to let you
try and do on your own before I help you
out I want to look at this spot here let
me just move this up a teeny bit there
we go see this line right here let me
just highlight it for you
this'll do this mark here right this is
what happened when we took our two
equations these two and then we sort of
jammed them into one equation do you
remember that and then we started to
factorize and then we started solve ok
now I just want you to in addition to
these two I'd love you to also add this
equation as a third one onto the King
you do that can you pop it in as well
3x minus x squared can you put that on
as well
okay now what I'm really interested is
what does this mean and what
relationship does it have to what we
just had a look at okay we started to
look at this red in the blue line and we
started to find their points of
intersection right but when we put those
two equations together the new equation
that we got at the end was this guy 3x
minus x squared and then we had 3x minus
x squared equals what what we're going
to look in you're working it's equal to
zero right that's the Green Line when is
it equal to zero
there's the x-axis right and you can see
look there's the zero the first solution
we found and then there's what's that
one that's three right that's the second
solution we found now can you see that
solving this one problem see where the
solutions line up is the same as solving
the original problem right where do the
red and blue intersect is the same
question as where is the green line
intersect with the x-axis so we've taken
this like more complicated problem with
like multiple things flying around and
converted it into a simpler one a single
quadratic equation that we could deal
with okay